new in theaters this weekend mama mia
here we go again unfriended dark web and
the equalizer - this is your weekend
ticket mama mia here we go again comes
out this weekend I wish every sequel was
here we go again like Jurassic world
here we go again Mamma Mia here we go
again is the sequel to the 2008 film
Mamma Mia which was based on the musical
Mamma Mia it's 10 years later and Sofie
is pregnant with Skye's baby Mamma Mia
here we go again indeed with even more
romantic comedy musical interludes and
family history revealed from the first
film Mamma Mia here we go again is a
movie you won't forget my my how could
you the star-studded cast returns with
Amanda Seyfried Christine Baranski
Pierce Brosnan Dominic Cooper Colin
Firth Andy Garcia cher Meryl and more
this movie is for you if you love the
original Musical or the first film you
love family musical romantic comedies or
you've always wanted to live in Greece
with your overly musical family do
this is darkweb we have to do something
you have to do it
who's that looking for a movie on the
big screen about videos on a smaller
screen then check out unfriended dark
web or as I call it unfriended here we
go again this is the standalone sequel
to 2014's film unfriended from the
creators of get out and Paranormal
Activity this found footage horror film
introduces a group of video chatting
chatting friends to the illegal and
nefarious world of the dark web murder
and mayhem ensues this film is for you
if you enjoy realistic feeling horror
films weird but I get it you like films
with an indie experimental vibe also
weird but I also get it or you need a
crash course on how the internet works
grandma I'm looking at you I'll call I
promise this weekend in theaters is
equalizer - or as I call it equalizer
here we go again
Denzel returns as Robert McCall a
retired CIA black ops operative who
comes out of retirement when he finds
out his friend has been murdered to find
the bad guys and take revenge oh do you
think Robert McCall and Liam Neeson's
character from taking our friends I just
want to see them do something like
really mundane like own a coffee shop
I've got a large double vanilla latte
for Carl's sorry Charles
director Antoine Fuqua is known for
other action thrillers like training day
Olympus is fun and the first equalizer
this movie is for you if you like
graphic action thrillers Denzel gives
you the tingles or you're the kind of
person who can't really see yourself
retiring some people just need to stay
busy you know and finally San Diego
comic-con is in full swing be sure to
check out all of our social pages for
exclusive
celebrity interviews that is your
weekend ticket comment with your best
here we go against equal names
and check back next week for another
installment of Tom Cruise does the
impossible we'll see you next time on
weekend ticket we go again
[Music]